this video highlights new and existing
view options for alignment tracks in the
GD V ncbi's genome data viewer will
focus on BAM alignment data that are
hosted remotely and how to view
haplotype structural variation but many
of the display options you'll see also
applied to viewing other types of data
such as blast results and SRA data I'll
start on the gdv homepage and for this
demo changed to the grch37 assembly and
click browse genome to load the remote
bam file use the user data and track
hubs menu I'll first point out the
supported file and data types and notice
that for remote Bam and VCF files the
directory you point to must contain the
corresponding index files ok I'll select
options add remote files and paste in
the URL for my file and I'll give the
new track a name trio and click Add you
see a warning but the data were added
successfully warnings like these report
incongruities between the file and the
genome assembly for instance that the
file contains extra sequences that are
not in the assembly details has more
specific information your added tracks
are placed at the bottom but you can
move any track by click and drag in the
tracks title bar I'm going to clean up a
bit by using the red X on the right to
delete some tracks and you might also
notice that the Edit track is shaded
green this differentiates user added
tracks from those provided by NCBI at
this zoom level we're seeing all of
chromosome 1 and the coverage graph of
reads in our trio track appears to show
good even coverage across the chromosome
this big gap is the centromere region
let's zoom in a bit and display a
specific 100 kilobases
by typing in the search widget on the
left I want to go to chromosome one
sixty nine thousand nine hundred K to
seventy thousand K
we're getting more detail at this level
where red denotes areas with more
mismatches and black denotes in dull
variation in the read coverage in the
region sixty nine thousand nine hundred
and forty K to sixty nine thousand nine
hundred and forty five K notice the dips
suggesting deletions relative to the
genome reference I'll zoom to this
region and we see two regions where most
of the reads have these deletions or
gaps I'll spend the next couple minutes
adjusting various tract settings to
explore some of the display options
available you can use the gear icon next
to the Delete icon in the track title or
the one in the tooltip I'll click on the
one in the tooltip and change a few
settings I'll check the box for show
pileup keeping the pileup display set to
match mismatched graph count and in the
hide alignments menu I'll choose to hide
both duplicates and bad reads in the
sort alignments by menu I'll choose
haplotype then hit apply the pileup
graph is just below the track title and
in this match mismatch graph count
display clearly marks the two in del
regions the reads are now clustered by
haplotype haplotype one haplotype two
and haplotype not set notice that
haplotype 2 does not have the deletions
seen in haplotype 1 let's use highlight
and zoom to sequence around the smaller
in del region on the left side
at this level all the mismatches
deletions the dark red lines and
insertions the blue bars are apparent
the length of an insertion correlates to
size of the blue bar okay let's look at
one of the other pileup display options
I'll go back into track settings and
change pileup display to match
mismatched table count but you see that
other options are available I'll hit
apply and the pileup table now indicates
the individual recounts for a match
mismatch gap or intron refer to the
legend on the left also higher counts
are shaded more darkly
you see this easily in the gap region
now let's take a look at a reads tooltip
there's a lot of good information there
a mouse over on a reads row activates
the tooltip and I'll click this pushpin
to keep it open so here we can get
orientation the span of that read on the
reference molecule percent coverage and
so on you also get a cigar string
and at the bottom you have a button
called view to see any unaligned regions
here the unaligned reads are in red and
you can copy/paste to the sequence for
further analysis for example to see if
this is vector sequence or part of a
translocation or chimera be aware that
this tooltip information is also present
for other types of alignment data such
as bam files for expression data or for
blast data the last example is a quick
look for NCBI refs naps in the region of
structural variation we've seen here I
want to add a track of those rest snips
so I'll go to the tracks menu configure
tracks and show the variation tracks we
can choose from let's go to the most
recent DB snip build 1:53 and select
live rest snips I'll then hit configure
here is the added ref snips track and
there is a red snip in this region the
RS ending in 8 0 6 6 in the tooltip for
the RS you get a link to the snip record
where you can investigate this further
that's all for this video we'd love to
have your questions and feedback so
please use either the feedback form in
the help menu or the support center link
near the bottom of most NCBI web pages